welsh writer ken follett has come to
cologne from london bringing the drizzle
along with him
just in time to mark the 25th
anniversary of the fall of the berlin
wall he unveils a present from his
german publisher
it's an original piece of the wall
painted like the cover of the german
edition of his latest book
the novel deals with the cold war the
era in which the wall still stood
separating the opposing eastern and
western blocks i remember the fall of
the wall and what i remember about that
is that we didn't believe it was
permanent
you know sitting in london
or and
the same for people who are in the
united states
uh
we saw this happening and we thought yes
but tomorrow the tanks will arrive
uh because we
you know we had seen this before in
hungary in czechoslovakia and poland
where there had been a kind of rebellion
against the
the uh communist system but in the end
the rebellion had been crushed and a lot
of us thought that the same thing was
bound to happen again
for edge of eternity ken follett did
lots of research on location
the book intertwines the stories of five
families from the us and europe much of
the action takes place in divided berlin
there are several scenes in edge of
eternity
where somebody tries to escape
and of course that kind of scene is all
about the physical detail you know how
high is the wall how far do they have to
jump
or or what is the barrier like that they
have to crash through
and all of that stuff
those details are terribly important um
and that was quite difficult to research
because
happily for all of us the wall is no
longer there
for the last 35 years the former
journalist has written one bestseller
after another ken follett's books have
sold around 130 million copies worldwide
i always wanted to be a star
right from a young age and uh you know
when i was very young i didn't care what
kind of star i just wanted to be a star
you know authors aren't supposed to say
that author's supposed to had a message
to give the world
and
it wasn't like that for me it wasn't
like that for me i wanted to entertain
people i wanted them to love my story
follett's latest novels end his century
trilogy which began with fall of giants
and winter of the world in edge of
eternity he follows the stories of the
same families whose fates are closely
linked to world history
well my stories are about quite
fundamental things that affect everybody
uh i i write about wars and revolutions
but also about love and marriage
and raising children
the the the dramas in my books are
things i think that most people can
identify with
and his fans just can't get enough
pollets readings are sold out affairs
like here in cologne the celebrity
author can't resist divulging
interesting tidbits
mimi alford
recently wrote a book about her affair
with president kennedy she kept the
secret for 50 years
she's an old lady now
and so i sent her an email and said
would you be one of my consultants
and she read the scenes in which the
young woman
goes to bed with president kennedy
and she made some corrections and she
gave me some additional information
followed
whose family comes from east germany
i told him things about my history and
my parents about how he lived in east
germany and how my parents prepared to
flee
he made some notes in his book and at
the end he told me i wrote down every
word you said i wrote down every word
you said
ken follett's next book is already in
the works
he plans to take his readers on another
trip back in time with a spy thriller
about the beginnings of the british
secret service in the 16th century